I'll leave those right there title the
book is the bielski brothers the true
story of three men who defied the Nazis
save twelve hundred Jews and built a
village in the forest it's the story of
Tuvia Zoosh and a soil Bielski the
strapping sons of a miller from a tiny
village in what is today Western Belarus
their achievement during World War two
is surely equal to that of Oskar
Schindler or the fighters of the Warsaw
Ghetto Uprising yet their story of
rescue and resistance is largely unknown
ask even the most knowledgeable student
World War 2 about these men and you will
likely get get a blank stare I stumbled
upon this story quite by accident I
spotted an internet reference to forest
Jews that described the story in brief
and simply for curiosity's sake we went
to the library to find out more when I
learned that the two brothers who
survived the war to view and Zoosh lived
in Brooklyn New York for decades largely
anonymous I was flabbergasted
why is there no statue of them why
aren't there any parades and that
inspired me to contact the family and I
soon began the process that will result
in this book I eventually interviewed
more than 50 survivors from the brothers
wartime group living throughout the
world and tracked down testimonies given
by those members who are no longer
living I traveled to Belarus where the
action of the story occurred and scoured
the newly accessible Soviet archives and
interviewed both Gentile allies and
enemies of the group one of my great
finds was a Yiddish language memoir
written by the oldest brother Tuvia
which had never before been cited by
scholars and was unknown to even his
family we have a quick overview of what
happened during the one what these men
did the story begins when the Germans
invade the Soviet Union in June 22nd
1941 and acted quickly to execute or to
imprison in ghettos all the Jews of the
bielski z' district in time the brothers
parents and two younger siblings were
killed the brothers succeeded in hiding
themselves and their nearest relatives
but urged by the oldest brother they
decided to offer refuge to every Jew
young or old
you're sick I would rather say one old
Jewish woman than kill ten Nazis Tuvia
Bielski would say and slowly this ragged
band grew in size it moved from Forest
to forest one step ahead of the Germans
and in a few instances avoided a German
onslaught by mere seconds
the brothers also slowly built up a
fighting force that attack German
installations in convoys and sought out
and punished Nazi collaborators and it
suffered surprisingly few losses during
these days for the final ten months of
the forest experience the bielski unit
now a thousand strong settled in a large
deep dense forest called a push jaw in
several Eastern European languages and
constructed a bustling Jewish village an
extraordinary place with tailors
shoemakers blacksmiths gunsmiths it had
a large kitchen a central square for
gatherings a mill powered by a horse
that walked in a circle a Main Street a
theatre troupe a tannery that doubled as
a synagogue and mind you this community
existed literally in the heart of Nazi
occupied territory in the summer of 1944
the Soviet Army pushed the Germans from
Western Belarus and on July 10 1944 59
years ago this summer some 1,200 Jews
walked out of the forest a return to the
nearest cities they found their people
massacred and their communities
destroyed the locals looked at them and
wondered are you ghosts and many people
I interviewed mention that to me during
this during the research for this book
and with nothing for them in the soviet
union the forest survivors began the
slow process of emigrating to the lands
where they would make their homes is
real Western Europe the United States
soil the second-oldest bielski brother
was conscripted into the Soviet Army and
he was killed fighting Germans in
February of 1945 two of Ian's Saoirse
emigrated to Israel where they worked
blue-collar jobs to feed their young
families and in the mid 1950s both men
moved to the United States to a
middle-class neighborhood in Brooklyn
New York
just a few blocks from each other Zeus
ran a trucking and taxi company while
Tuvia
the great commander who in fact once
wrote a white horse in the
in the woods now I would that detail is
almost too good to be true
but in fact I have many sources for it
so he did ride a white horse for time he
was a typical immigrant truck driver
delivering plastic raw plastic materials
to companies throughout the metropolitan
New York area never obviously equaling
the success that he had during the war -
he died in 1987 and Zoosh died in 1995
I'd like to show a couple quick slides
that give an overview of the story and
then I'll take some questions so this is
the area we're speaking of here this is
a the force would have been just below
that circle there to the east of Minsk
is where the main action of the story
took place Lithuania to the north what
is now Russia to the east Poland to the
West and the Ukraine to the south okay
this is Tuvia the oldest brother the
visionary and charismatic visionary and
charismatic man who deemed that the
group would save all Jews that it could
that was controversial and he met it
when there about 16 or 17 members of the
group most of whom said let's save
ourselves and and not worry about
everyone else and he insisted to his to
his great credit to do that and I think
it makes him one of the great leaders of
world war two and this is a soil the
second oldest brother who's two years
younger than Tuvia
he was the loyal more quiet taciturn
brother and if there was no war he
likely would have remained on the
family's mill and and lived out his life
as a simple farmer this is the third
oldest brother the younger of the three
zushio or Zoosh and he was the brash the
brash brother he would throw punches
first and ask questions later in fact
he's wearing a Nazi uniform there that
he took off a man he killed in an ambush
German officer in an ambush in 1944 go
ahead this is where they grew up in town
kovitch and what is today Western
Belarus and throughout the years it has
been held by Russia Lithuania Poland
Germany you name it any of the
neighboring countries and on the crest
of that Hill was about 12 homes they
were Gentile families and the only
Jewish family in the town was the Bell
skis and they were on this side of the
water just off to the left of the
picture and they had the mill that was
powered by this waterway this is David
Gonski the patriarch of the family
unlike his three sons he had a more
conciliatory nature when bandits came
calling he would ply them with vodka
anything that would get them to leave
peacefully this is the next village over
a shot I took during my visit there and
the woman in this in this home in fact
sheltered two via the oldest brother for
a time during the war he would come from
the village to check out enemy activity
and that kind of thing she described to
me how she would put a little bit of
straw on the ground and he would he
would lay and rest for a couple of hours
before returning to the woods and of
course that she would have been easily
killed for doing that by the Germans
this is the shot from her house looking
back towards the woods you get a sense
of where he was coming from and where
they were living go ahead this is a
photograph of the court house in the
nearest decent sized city a city of
about 10,000 before the war novogrudok
and a couple months into the German
occupation they rounded up the entire
Jewish population of that town about six
thousand maybe a little more 7,000
brought them to this location and
selected them selected forty five
hundred of them out on December 8th 1941
and took them to a site south of the
town to a clearing in the woods
go ahead where they were executed in a
manner similar to this which is a bullet
in the back of the head and falling into
a pit that had been pre dug and this is
that site today the bell-to-bell ski
parents David that I just showed was
killed and the mother were killed on
that day and for many years it was a
Soviet marker here saying that Soviet
citizens had been killed on this site
but since independence a Jewish marker
was putting there a proper marker
marking what it actually truly happened
there
and this is am and a friend of the
bielski brothers constantine kozlovskiy
a a Gentile belarusian simple peasant
who when the brothers realized what was
happening that was to befall their
people he agreed to go into the ghetto
that of that city of novogrudok and
bring notes urging people to flee and
also he offered his house on the edge of
the woods to serve as a way station for
those who did flee the ghetto that who
would be on eventually on their way to
the brothers forest encampment and he he
was a great hero the great hero of the
story one of the great heroes of this
story and people have estimated he saved
100 Jews perhaps more and there you
don't find men like this during these
days as the brothers begin a rescue
operation they also begin thinking about
fighting and this is the Soviet
government was only happy to - happy to
urge them to fight and these were
typical propaganda message urging all
Soviet citizens to fight for the
motherland and they were hearing these
messages on as well as posters like this
on the radio and they began thinking of
doing that go ahead this is a forest one
of the early encampments was in this
forest and that hole right there would
have been much larger during the war
much wider and deeper but it was
according to a man who took me back into
the woods it was a sight of where they
don't where they made a dugout which
enabled them to survive the cold weather
what they would do is dig down deep into
the ground and build a roof angled roof
on the top of it and used the the
earthen walls to keep in the heat and
that's how they survived that first
winter and the subsequent winter this is
the butts kovitch force not far from mr.
Kozlowski's house that I just showed
earlier go ahead and during these days
they run they run across the Russian men
and Victor pond ching-kuo and he was
thinking of fighting the Germans just as
the brothers were during these days and
he was in that very same area and he
could have been a great enemy to the
brothers many Russian partisans were
very suspicious of Jews would take their
guns which
shoot them further for their for their
boots something as minor as that but he
was a 21 year old who was eager to fight
and eager to make allies in that and he
became a quick and great ally of the
three brothers and they worked together
to to attack German installations and
one of the German installations the
victor group and the bielski group
attacked was a was this rail line where
there was a nearby train station just
off to the left of this photograph they
also attacked a convoys and in November
of 1942 the Jewish group killed their
first Nazi officer that was several
months before the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising
so it was a armed Jewish resistance very
early on in the scope of the war
go ahead during these days the brothers
are going out into the countryside
countryside like this to get food from
the peasants and this man is describing
where ten Jews from the from the
brothers group were killed ambushed when
a collaborator told the Germans what
they were doing they're hiding in a
house staying during the daytime they
couldn't move in the daytime they could
only move at night because of the enemy
activity and they were a collaborator
went to the Germans and told them where
they were sleeping they ran from the
house and ran towards the woods and this
man is describing where they were killed
and they were buried where they fell in
fact his father did the burying and he
room he was about 13 years old during
the war he remembered the story very
well and this these were they kind of
while the group was very successful in
these in this first year these are the
sorts of hazards they had constantly
what this is a deep dense force where
they went to to try to avoid those kind
of dangers they went to achieve this the
push Jay as I described earlier this is
the nollie baka push go a Polish woman
who took me back into the woods where
the where the brothers had a camp and
they hoped that this deep dense force
much farther far away from there about
40 kilometers from their boyhood home
would be much safer and they wouldn't
have the kind of incidents as I just
described there but when they arrived
they faced there
greatest obstacle yet a German officer
here by the name of Oscar Guerra longer
and many many other vicious German
troops surrounded that deep dense forest
and proceeded to attack it from all
sides so it was far greater than
anything the brothers had yet faced up
to that point and this is the summer of
1943 and go ahead this is the typical
German operation scouring the woods for
any sign of life and of course they
didn't care whether you were militant or
whether you civilian they were only too
happy to to shoot go ahead this is with
nothing else to do no no idea of how to
respond the brothers went through the
swamps and this is a picture of a man a
man made for me in Israel or may a maid
drew in Israel a man who experienced
this of what they did they went through
the deep swamps to an island they had
heard of in the middle of this deep
dense forest and there were children on
top of people's shoulders they were
holding the guns over the head they had
to abandon everything they had collected
up to this point bullets were whizzing
over the head the Germans had brought
loudspeakers into the woods to urge them
to surrender or they would all die go
ahead and and they reached this spot
crossing the Agora an island in the
middle of this deep dense forest and
they stayed there they were without food
for ten days many feared that this would
be their final resting place the German
onslaught continued around them they
were able to to make it here and in
safety yet without food and they waited
ten days and finally the German guns
subsided and they were able to come out
from this part to us to a drier part of
the forest and begin to create the large
camp that I described earlier no people
were killed during this no members of
the group the group was about 900 people
800 people at this point and no one died
during this extraordinary 2-week period
going and so when they came out of the
woods they built this large force and
one of the thing one of the we're sorry
this large camp and we have shoemakers
in that and that large village that they
created and these are shoes
boots that were created in the woods
shown to me by a woman named Celia Ruben
and from Fort Lee New Jersey and go
ahead and we could see the little bit of
the handiwork there of the forest
cobblers
there were shoemakers there were tailors
they were gunsmiths there were you name
it they were many many workshops that
existed in this extraordinary village go
ahead and this is a photograph of about
that time during the war the 40 members
of the group of the brothers group armed
and unarmed men and women they this was
a photograph that was taken near a
landing strip that was built in that
large forest the Soviets who the
brothers were increasingly allied with
at this point had created a landing
strip for four planes Red Army planes
that brought in supplies it was a safe
time it was a time when they were
finally able to breathe in the final
months of the war but and this is Tuvia
the oldest brother's widow luca and one
of the great joys of this project was
meeting the three widows of the three
brothers they had survived the forest
years they had been through it all and
they were quite eager to tell the story
they were proud proud guardians of their
husband's memory and mrs. bielski here
was a regal woman extraordinary lady who
who unfortunately passed away before the
book was before she was able to see the
book published which is a great regret
to me this is haya belsky a soils second
oldest brother's widow she was in Haifa
Israel when I interviewed her and she
still is their loquacious lady wonderful
talker extraordinary memory and I sat
with her for many many days I hear - a
wonderful city but I didn't see much of
it because I was speaking with her for
quite a long time thank you
and finally sonya zhu xi's widow the
pugnacious and irrepressible sonia who
and this is a photograph of her in
brooklyn new york with her husband right
there close at hand and she's a great
lady we she was on CNN a couple weeks
ago and she was taking phone calls the
next day like she was a prime minister
she
was she was really enjoying it she's a
great lady thank you and I'm only too
happy to take any questions and before
we do that I have one dignitary in the
audience I'd like to introduce two via
Bielski the oldest brother his son is
here one of his sons Robert bielski you
happen to be in Philadelphia thank you
very much for coming any questions it
was a it changed throughout the course
of their experience in the first year of
the being in the woods they were in
small forest not far from settlements
they knew the Gentile population because
this was areas where the brothers
themselves had grown up they were able
to use their strengths to either
intimidate them if they weren't
necessarily friendly or they'd to use
them as friends if they were in fact
friends so these early forests were
simply carved out of near small villages
and this giant forest at the end pushka
was miles upon miles upon miles of
forest land with very few roads going in
a very little human habitation and most
of it was swampy these days in the 1960s
the Soviet government went in to try to
drain the swamps to make some arable
farmland but it didn't work too well so
you don't see the swamps these days but
it was swampy it was marshy and the word
it was a great area to hide if you
needed to hide in fact bandits and and
anyone who was escaping the whoever
happened to be running the government in
the city had done that for centuries
running to places like that
just curious what was your total
commitment in terms of active
involvement in this project I stumbled
upon the story it was my initial
attraction to it was this in the image
of three three brothers on horseback
with submachine guns strapped over their
shoulders riding through the forest and
creating this community is an amazing
image that struck me immediately and I
just it was simple curiosity that
brought me to it and simple going simply
going to the people who would who lived
through it
finding the documents that referred to
it and scouring whatever I could in it
we just slowly grew to be a story that I
that I felt very deeply about and I had
no real connection to it before I began
this but but by the end I felt a very
strong connection and it was very
powerful for me I began in 2000 some
three years
yeah the this began for me as a as an
english-language story about New York
City about two men the two surviving
brothers who lived in Brooklyn in the
sense of hidden hidden heroes and sense
of they had lived so many years quite
enough mostly anonymous to most of the
world so it began as an english-language
story as I got deeper into it it became
a Yiddish language story or Hebrew
language Polish Russian Belarusian so I
don some very good translators
unfortunately I don't I can't speak all
those languages I wish I could you know
the german general that what happened
being bodega kitchen yeah Darrell anger
Terrell vaanga eventually who was he was
killed at the end of the war I there was
some controversy about that for many
years but a historian had as finally I
think French Maclean's book the cruel
hunters reveals that he was killed I
believe by the Soviets at the end of the
war so he didn't make it to freedom
although some suspected that he had but
he infected
that community entirely Jewish or than
join my other partisans
that I was entirely Jewish and there
were one or two three or four Gentiles
that were there they were off they would
be married to Jews the only reason they
would have been allowed to be there but
yeah it was a purely Jewish village it
was they well in fact the second brother
was taken into the Red Army they had to
work very hard when they came out of the
woods they were immediately
the Soviets immediately wanted to know
everything wanted them to come to Mintz
to be debriefed did have a very
intensive interrogation of them about
what had happened and in immediately
Tuvia the oldest brother felt that it
wasn't safe for him he did everything he
could in the months immediately
immediately following liberation to
avoid any Soviet leaders and eventually
when the time was right they simply fled
the country got out with fake papers
anybody else well thank you very well
one question going
most of them began made it to Western
Europe to Israel to America there were
some that stayed behind in the Soviet
Union I it's tough for me to estimate
exactly how many I would say less than
10% I met a few when I was over there
but most of them made it out most of
them came out of the woods to find
nothing for them their communities were
gone so there was nowhere for them to go
so the initial instinct was fine find a
home a new home far away from where this
had happened I the historians have known
of it it has been out there that have
been written accounts the brothers in
fact in 1946 when they arrived in Israel
told their story but is probably a
number of factors when they arrived in
Israel there was immediately another
there was a war of independence that
they fought in when they came to this
country in the 50s they were their
English their skills with the English
wasn't they didn't speak the language
very well they were busy supporting
families a it's tough to say and for the
the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising I think
represents to to the world really Jewish
resistance and Nazism and perhaps we can
only have one story like that I don't
know so I thought about it but it's it's
really sort of a mystery why one thing
one story catches and others don't